The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: When did
you arrive at MIT?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: I was
a post-doc in 1980.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I just
remember that.
PROFESSOR: So Ros is also a
historian of technology.
But she practices the craft
a little different
than David and I do.
She focuses on the cultural
side of things and is an
expert in literature and what
writers have said about
technological change
and has written a
lot about those subjects.
But also, she served
as the dean of
undergraduate education.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: And
student affairs.
I did both jobs.
PROFESSOR: I didn't know
if I had the title.
There was one time when you
didn't have two deans.
You didn't a dean for
residential life.
You had them combined
in one office.
And she got stuck with that
job, which is as you might
imagine, is a lot of work.
And so Ross did that
for at least six--
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Five years.
PROFESSOR: Five years.
So that's been a big
item on her agenda.
And now, she's back
in the department.
And today, she's going to talk
about chemical engineering
basically, in the early
20th century.
And this is extremely
interesting.
She gave a lecture about
it last year.
Because her grandfather
was Warren K. Lewis.
If any of are familiar with the
"Lewis Report" of the late
1940s, that's the report that in
effect that established the
School of Humanities and
Social Sciences.
But here's a chemical engineer
who is a very much involved
and looking at all aspects of
life at MIT and coming up with
this report.
And as they say, the
rest is history.
So Ros has a long lineage here,
that your grandfather
goes back to the early
1900s, I would say.
Didn't he get here--
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: He
was class of '05.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So she's going to talk
about this area.
And she's brought some very
interesting materials I'm
anxious to look at.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: So I wanted
to do something new this time.
And that's why in the
last hour, I went
though my Lewis box.
Archives are just
boxes of stuff.
This is from my attic.
And the library's is just
not that different.
And I pulled out some little
treasures, at least I think
they're treasures, that will
give you a flavor of what
archives are like and when
you're doing history, what you
learn from archives that you
don't learn online, can't
learn online.
I may overstate that.
I may take that back.
But I'll stand by it for
a talking point.
So I'm going to start with
giving you an overview of
intertwined biography of Warren
K. Lewis and of the
world here in the Boston area,
Cambridge, and MIT
specifically, as they
intertwined.
And in discussing afterwards, we
can talk about him, we can
talk about chemical
engineering.
We can also talk about
deanly things.
If you're interested in student
life history, I've
done a little boning up on that
for a documentary that
was being shot last week
about the evolution of
student life at MIT.
So I sort of refreshed my memory
about some points on
that topic.
So we talk about anything
you want to talk about.
But first of all, let me give
you some what my grandfather
used to say, you want to put
the fodder down where the
calves can get at it.
So I'm going to put
out some fodder.
Fodder is food, so cow food.
They say you've got
to put it down.
So I'm putting it down.
And we'll chew on this
together and then see
where it takes us.
So this is this kind of
biographical history of
chemical engineering at MIT.
I remember my grandfather
sitting in the living room
holding forth, as he was
wont to do, in Newton,
Massachusetts.
This is where he lived with my
grandmother and mother and
three other siblings.
He was a boarder in
the household
and married the daughter.
And this is a little part
history right there.
Most MIT students, there
weren't residences.
So you boarded with families or
you were in a fraternity.
So boarding was very common.
Let me just me just mention
something about his family.
You see his dates.
His father was born in 1845,
in Laurel, Delaware.
And his father, my grandfather's
grandfather, had
been born in the kind of,
well, mid to late 1700s.
He had three wives.
My grandfather's father
was the last child
of the third wife.
So there's a huge gap in the
half-brothers, between Henry
Clay Lewis, Henry Clay Lewis,
that's the name of my
grandfather's father, and the
first wife's, first child.
Many of these children died.
But this is just a part of
history, the fact that if I go
from my grandfather, to his
father, to his father, I'm
back to the Revolutionary War.
Because his grandfather had a
brother who died in a prison
ship, moored in the Hudson
River during the
Revolutionary War.
So it's just amazing to me that
you just take a few steps
and you're back in
time, like that.
This is Delaware.
Delaware was a slave state.
It was a slave-owning family.
Also an abolitionist family,
which is a strange
combination.
But it's one of those, it's a
nice idea, but not until I die
will I free my slaves, family.
And that's what happened.
But his father was one of the
two votes for Abraham Lincoln
in his county in Delaware
in 1860.
And his father--
God, these dates don't
seem right.
Because if his father
is born in 18--
OK.
It was his grandfather, his last
vote was for Abe Lincoln,
that's it, in Laurel,
Delaware.
If you look at the history of
slavery in Laurel, what's
fascinating is that next door
was Maryland, where slaves
could be traded, but
not in Delaware,
after a certain date.
You may know that.
But in Delaware, you could
hold slaves, but you
couldn't sell them.
So there's a huge kidnapping
ring, where people from
Maryland would go just over the
border to Laurel, kidnap
either free blacks or slaves,
take them back to Maryland,
where they could be sold
for a huge profit.
Because at that time, they could
still be sold to other
parts of the United States.
So Delaware, Laurel was the
site of the Patty Cannon
kidnapping ring, which is
a fascinating story.
But it's not the story
I'm here to tell.
But it does give context.
This is a farm boy.
Kenny was raised on the farm
in Laurel, Delaware.
Expecting to say on the farm,
and his life, he got hijacked
by the 20th century.
These are just some more
pictures holding forth.
That's a very familiar
pose, very familiar.
PROFESSOR: You know it well.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah.
I mean as a granddaughter,
you knew this guy.
Students were terrified of him
because he'd get you up here.
And you'd start doing something
on the board.
And you wouldn't know
what you were doing
and he would pounce.
But as a granddaughter, it was
just a very affectionate
relationship.
I was aware how much he
terrified other people.
But that was not my relationship
with him.
That's the farmhouse, still
in a Laurel, Delaware.
It used to be a bed and
breakfast not that long ago.
I don't think it's in
business anymore.
That's my brother.
That's more Warren K. Lewis,
Jr., my uncle, and my
grandfather.
This is in 1952.
He has just sold the farm.
Heart breaking, because it had
been in the family back to the
late 1700s.
But a part of the farm was cut
through by a road, the dual,
they call it there,
a dual highway.
Route 14 cut through a corner of
the farm and he realized it
was never going to be a
working farm again.
And the irony is of course that
part of the reason for
putting in that highway is that
DuPont had established
big factories in northern
Delaware.
And there's more commuter
traffic from south to north.
So chemical engineering,
in a sense,
destroyed the family farm.
And I say there's
a sort of irony.
There's quite a bit
of irony there.
Not to mention the fact that the
whole automobile age was
in part made possible through
new methods of refining
petroleum, using catalytic
cracking, that my grandfather
directly worked on.
This is not the best-- but this
is the Eastern Shore,
this peninsula.
The Chesapeake Bay is here.
So Baltimore is up
around here.
Washington is kind of off
the map, over here.
And Philadelphia is
to the north.
But this is the Eastern Shore.
And it's Virginia down here.
You can't see the map--
the split division.
So last time I went, I go to
the airport in Baltimore, I
drive over the Chesapeake Bay
Bridge, I go down to roads,
about right in the middle.
And that takes me two hours.
So you go from one end to the
other in a couple hours.
With the dual, you
go fast, yeah.
So there is a Maryland
over here.
Oh, you can see the
dotted line, OK.
So this is Maryland over here.
This is where like Dick Cheney
lives now, in Easton.
It's very high, upper crust.
And this is Delaware,
which is much more
farming, much more rural.
And then Virginia down here.
It's pretty rustic.
The Chincoteague ponies,
Chincoteague is one of these
islands off of here.
So this is a garden spot in the
18th and 19th centuries.
It is the truck garden area
for the Philadelphia and
Baltimore markets, raising
mainly corn, fruits,
vegetables, peaches, tomatoes,
live stock.
It's mixed farming.
And I'll tell you some more
about that as we go on.
But the reason I have this map--
this is from Bob Post--
the railroad comes to
Laurel in 1859.
And that opens up the whole
area to commercial
farming much more.
I mean it had always been
such, but even more.
Now, my grandfather's
grandfather was a sea captain.
Farming was his--
that's where the wife
and kids stayed.
But he made his money in the
trade, starting from the
Chesapeake, doing a lot of
trade of the Caribbean.
So that's where his
money came from.
I mean he was a large,
established farmer and the
state legislator.
So he was a politician.
But he was a well-off person
for Delaware, but still
basically a sea captain
and a farmer.
So the railroad comes.
And this is sort of getting
ahead of the story.
But my grandfather born in
1882, he goes through the
three-year high school
in Laurel, Delaware.
And learns everything you learn
there, because there's
one teacher for all grades,
in one classroom.
And his parents want him to
get a better education.
He's an only child.
He's obviously going to
inherit the farm.
So they want him to go to a
better high school than the
Laurel one.
So his cousin, she's actually
a cousin I guess.
He had an older female cousin
named Mary Witherby, who had
left Laurel to teach school,
like her father, and she was
teaching school at the Lasell
Female seminary, which still
exists around here.
Do any of you--
you know what I'm
talking about.
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It's
now Lasell College.
It used to be junior college,
now college.
Yeah, and it's in West Newton,
just a stone's
throw from your place.
So my grandfather was sent up
by his parents to live in
Newton, go to high school.
Newton High was famous even
then as a good school.
He would board with
the family.
But he had his cousin in town.
And she would look after him
and make sure he didn't get
into too much trouble.
This house is a block away
from where I live now.
I go there all the time.
So that's still there, one of
the older houses in the
neighborhood.
So this is where he boarded.
Now, I happen to have his diary
from his first full
winter at Hunnewell
Avenue in Newton.
And it starts January
10, 1898 and it
goes through the spring.
So I'm a little mixed up about
the timing, because I believe
this is his second year I
believe at Newton High.
His first year he came up, he
got an A in arithmetic, a D in
drawing, and F's in
everything else.
So it was not a good high school
he was coming from.
And he really had to catch up.
By this time, I think it's the
second year, he's got his feet
under him and he's
doing better.
So he's boarding in
the winter of '98.
And I just want to read a few
little details that will give
you a sense of what life was
like, daily life was like for
him at that time.
This is the Second Industrial
Revolution, is what we call it
from up here.
But down here, this
is what it's like.
After school, this is high
school, he says, this is
January 12, I went up to Lasell
and read Cicero with
cousin Mary.
Who's Cicero?
What does this tell you?
You read Cicero in Latin.
You start with doing Cicero.
You wind up with Cicero
and Virgil.
So he's reading his Latin
with his cousin.
And then she gave me a supper
of canned chicken, cocoa,
bread, butter, crackers,
and peanut butter.
I had a fine time.
OK, canned chicken?
I mean I don't have
to rub this in.
You can figure this out.
This is not off the farm.
Canned chicken, cocoa, you know
we're dealing with the
Caribbean at least, if that's
not the East Indies.
Bread, butter, all
right, crackers--
packaged food-- and
peanut butter.
OK.
So he mentions that-- at home,
he got a letter from home.
And the letter from home says
four factories were going up
in Laurel and vicinity
for canning.
He, my father--
this is my grandfather's father,
he is going to put out
10 acres of tomatoes.
He has only four cows now.
So there's a lot of agricultural
history there.
There's a new canning factory,
more tomatoes, fewer cows.
So just to jump ahead, my
grandfather would say that he
paid for his MIT tuition when he
got to MIT, with tomatoes,
sold to a cannery at $4 a ton.
PROFESSOR: Jesus, $4 a ton.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: $4 a ton.
Now, he had the bright
idea, during his
college years, of recycling.
That is, using the tomato skins,
which are removed in
the canning process, or they
tried to remove them, using
those skins to feed to
the cows as fodder.
And they tried it.
The cows ate them.
But then they gave pink milk.
So it didn't work.
OK, just a few more of
these from his diary.
We're still back in
January 1898.
Today, as I was walking home
from school, cousin Mary in
the electrics--
so what are the electrics?
PROFESSOR: Trolleys.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Trolleys.
OK, the street car suburbs--
this is a little digression.
But this is showing how the
electric trolley system was
being extended at the time.
This is the Sam Best Warner's
classic study.
And the trolley, which I
remember from my childhood,
near Hunewell Avenue, where he
lived, is just a block away.
You can just walk.
In fact, now it's
a bus system.
But it's the same route.
And you can get on where
we live and go to
Fenway Park in one stop.
PROFESSOR: No wonder you live
in that neighborhood.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Of
course, you got it.
Then we went into Boston.
Cousin Mary in the electrics,
saw me, got out and walked
home with me.
Then we went into Boston.
Now, this would have been on the
train track, which is the
other side of the hill
that he's looking on.
Went into Boston.
And she bought two tin basins,
a pie pan, a strainer, and a
dozen knives and forks.
She carried it in a mug strainer
belonging to the
coffee pot, to fit the strainer
she brought to it.
So she's buying a piece
for her coffee pot.
She's buying all this
stuff, taking the
electrics into Boston.
So this tells you a lot
about technological
systems of the day.
But I think my favorite
entry from this
diary, this is in February.
He says, I went downtown.
This would be Newton Corner.
I went downtown in the evening
and rode, R-O-D-E, underlined.
I asked a man passing, for
a ride, and he consented.
It was the first time,
underlined, I've ridden,
underlined, on or behind a horse
since last September,
and I a farmer's boy.
So there's cars, there's
trolleys, there's trains.
But he wants to ride the horse,
because that's what
farmers; boys did.
There's a lot.
I could go on and on
about what you find
out from this diary.
There's a lot of reading,
Cicero, Shakespeare.
There's a lot of magazines.
He's reading magazines a lot.
He's going to church.
There are church plays.
There are glee club performances
at Lasell.
He goes into Boston for lectures
at the temple,
Fremont Temple.
He goes to the Museum of Fine
Arts, still with us, discusses
modern illustrators who
are exhibited there.
Then cousin Mary gives
him some pictures.
But I mean it is an information
age, in its own way.
It's just a different
kind of media.
But he's very connected.
So, for example, on January
20, he says he goes into
Boston to hear a lecture
on imperialism
by Dr. Lyman Abbott.
Now why in 1898, is he going to
a lecture on imperialism?
What's going on?
What's the news?
Anybody know?
AUDIENCE: Spanish-American
War.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: OK?
Which--
PROFESSOR: He said it.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS:
Spanish-American War, go to
the head of the class, yeah.
And it's interesting.
He says the lecture was a fine
one in favor of staying to
help them, the Filipinos in
this case, learn to govern
themselves.
And then he goes to another
lecture the next week, same
topic, another speaker, who
also make good points.
But cousin Mary said
some bad ones.
He attacked, the second speaker,
Dr. Abbott, the first
speaker, saying he had made some
misstatements concerning
the arguments on Californian
annexation and made McKinley
out as having imperial power.
So there's debate going on.
And then on February 7, we
received our first news
yesterday of the Battle
of Manila.
Reports of dead and wounded,
the gunboats
did a fearful execution.
Then there's Washington's
birthday soon after, the
church bells ring all day.
And my grandfather writes, these
are signs to me that it
is the anniversary of the
birth of the greatest
American, underlined,
ever borne.
OK, anyway.
PROFESSOR: It wasn't
Abe Lincoln.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Um, true.
PROFESSOR: It was GW.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It was GW.
How about that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, her--
yeah, but her--
it would be your great
grandfather's--
whose name is Henry Clay.
Now, Henry Clay--
ROSALIND WILLIAMS:
That's another--
yeah.
PROFESSOR: But Henry Clay
was Abraham Lincoln's
great idol in a way.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: I mean the
story of this family and
slavery is just fascinating.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's very
interesting, very interesting.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Well, I just
showed you this paper of
my grandmother's, my
grandfather's wife, on the
Negro problem in 1921.
Because my grandfather, he
wanted to go back to the farm
and improve race relations by
starting that farm up again in
the right way.
And that never happened.
But that was the idea.
OK, instead what happens?
In the spring, he asked two
teachers at Newton High what
they thought would be best for
him to do about college?
They will think it
over, he writes.
But the former advised either
Amherst Agricultural--
what's that?
PROFESSOR: New Mass.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah, it's
the University of Amherst now,
the Ag School-- other Amherst
agriculture, or as even
better, tech.
One of them mentioned
Cornell, but tech.
Here we are.
So he thinks about it.
By the way, this is just a
picture of downtown Boston,
when they take the
train in there.
I was there Friday, meeting
my son and his girlfriend.
It's not--
they're not people
like I know.
And I was saying to my son, oh
gee, my grandparent's would be
so distressed to see this.
And he said-- he has a place
in Fort Point, he said.
But that's up and coming.
That needs to be [INAUDIBLE].
And now, it's happening.
But let me just mention, I mean
these are quick reminders
that the occupation of
engineering was growing very
quickly at the time.
And that the people who went
into engineering--
my grandfather is very typical,
in being off the farm
and not particularly
well educated.
This is the way for young men,
almost always young men, to
have a professional or
quasi-professional career,
without having to consider
postgraduate study, like law
or divinity or medicine
required.
So here's Boston Tech.
You must have seen this picture
somewhat, in this class.
Here's Trinity Church
in Copley Square.
This is Boston Tech?
PROFESSOR: It's Boston Tech.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah.
And I've seen other photos where
I can't really place it.
So I would love to see somebody
do a sort of up to
date GPS showing exactly--
AUDIENCE: So that's
still there.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: That's
there, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then across the
street from that building is
Brooks Brothers, on Berkeley
Street, across from
[INAUDIBLE].
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: This is all
one big building there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There's actually a
plaque on the front of that
office building
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: But there was
another building, not the
Rogers Building, but
another building,
like off to the side.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It would be in that direction.
AUDIENCE: There's a
bunch of stuff.
Mark Jarzombek showed us a map,
and sort of to the right
of where the photograph is.
There's train tracks
and stuff there.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Now, the
steep steps, was that on this
building, on the Rogers
Building, or the second one?
PROFESSOR: I think
it's right there.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Oh, there.
PROFESSOR: Right there.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Oh, OK.
OK.
Because again, my grandfather
had a story about a kind of a
riot involving Harvard and MIT
students and a fire and he was
on the witness stand.
And it had to do
with the steps.
Some things don't change.
AUDIENCE: Mark talked
about the difference
between those two--
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: These
two buildings.
AUDIENCE: --buildings.
But they're separated by
a couple of decades.
But closer is a custom-built
laboratory, where you can see
the fumes of the vents coming
at the top there.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Oh, that
has happened here.
That's fascinating.
So in the subway spot at
Kimball, it says the second
building MIT build was
a gym, a gymnasium?
Does anybody--
I just read it there the
other day, thinking
that's the first I knew.
So Warren K. Lewis enters MIT
in 1901, planning to study
chemical engineer-- excuse me,
mechanical engineering, still
the dominant engineering, kind
of the default mode.
But he had a friend, this friend
that he was boarding
with in Newton, whose sister he
eventually married, urged
him to try chemical
engineering.
It seemed more interesting
and so on and so forth.
So as you know from your
reading, something like
industrial chemistry
had begun.
Actually, it was 1888, I think
was the first offerings in
industrial chemistry.
And by 1893, there was a lab.
This is sort of like the
first start of chemical
engineering at MIT.
But then because of deaths and
departures, it sort of declined.
But just when my grandfather's
was entering, actually in
1903, this is when Walker
comes back.
And Noyes had been there
for a couple years.
So it's sort of like a
false start early on.
And then it kind of
restarted around
the turn of the century.
And this is something that he
wrote many years later, that I
think captures the overall
feeling of the time.
Lewis wrote, the stimulus of
these concepts, and he's
referring to unit operations
and these related concepts,
the stimulus of these concepts
made work in chemical
engineering at the Institute
from 1902 to the outbreak of
World War I an inspiration for
both staff and student, which
it is impossible to describe.
So these are happening years.
I mean the tension between
Noyes and Walker is a
productive tension.
They had each other
to play off of.
And they certainly did.
By the way, you know
Walker, that's not
Walker, Memorial Walker.
Walker Memorial is named after
Francis Amasa Walker, one of
the early presidents.
Have I got it right?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: And we're
talking about William Walker.
It's no relation.
So it's important to
those straight.
So you have these two very
strong personalities.
This is Noyes, trained in
Germany, a physical chemist.
And really brought in serious
chemistry to the program,
beginning in 1902.
And then you have William H.
Walker, who had also been
educated in Germany, Penn State
and Gottingen, both.
And was teaching analytical
chemistry, the partner of A.D.
Little, which was originally
Little and Walker.
So he was entrusted with
Course 10 in 1903.
And was entrusted with building
it up into a chemical
engineering curriculum.
Now this, you can't read.
But I will read to you, because
this is Walker's
statement written years later.
This was after he
had left MIT.
This is either from the late
'20s or early '30s--
well, he died in the '30s.
So this is his statement of
what he was trying to do.
It's a fascinating statement.
So I'm going to read you
what Walker wrote.
What an industry needed was not
a man who had been taught
what the industry already knew,
but rather a man who was
trained to do what the
industry had not
been able to do.
The ideal man for the industries
was one who had
been given a sound knowledge
of chemistry and physics.
And then as a part of the
curriculum, had been given
systematic experience in the
application of this knowledge
to the solution of industrial
problems.
That he should not be a
specialist, but a solver of
problems, any kind of problem
that industry might present.
And then he goes on to say, this
idea met opposition, both
from established courses
of chemical
instruction and from industry.
And the industry thought
it was too theoretical.
But the scientists thought it
was too industry oriented.
So Walker is on this very nice
edge between not trying to
give into one or the other.
And then he goes on and says--
this at the top of the second
paragraph, I love this--
to prove the soundness
of this idea, I
returned to MIT in 1903.
And after a hot fight with
both the chemical and the
engineering faculties, I
reconstructed Course X as a
general educational course
without options.
And without options, that turns
out to be important.
So this is a feisty guy.
And I'm sure that's one reason
he and my grandfather got
along very well.
They were both feisty people,
very self assured.
But my grandfather always would
say, it is Walker who
invented chemical engineering
in this country.
He did not claim that
for himself at all.
But again, my grandfather
studied.
With Noyes.
You know, I was just reminding
you, this is particularly in
Servos's article.
My grandfather studied with
Noyes, took P-Chem from him,
and graduating in the
class of '05.
My grandfather's is this kind of
this grim-- he looks-- kind
of a grim looking guy.
And you'll see another
picture.
I'll pass it around.
In the spring of his senior
year, he expected to go back
to the farm, as much as you and
I expect the Sun to come
up tomorrow.
However, he got a job in the
lab, I think with Noyes.
And then that led to somebody,
I don't know whether it was
Noyes or Walker, one of them
suggested that he apply for a
traveling fellowship which
was being offered.
And it was $1,000 stipend, which
is that day and age was
a lot of money.
A traveling fellowship,
he could go
anywhere for a doctorate.
And so he really was
not interested.
But one of them basically
appealed to his competitive
spirit and kind of said well, if
you don't get it, somebody
else is going to get it.
And $1,000 sounded very nice.
He applied, got it and was on
his way to Breslau, in what is
now Germany, it's kind of on the
Polish-German border, for
graduate school the next year.
Later, he found he was in fact
the only applicant that year.
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
interesting.
Think about what the Harvard
class of 1905, where they
might have chosen to have
their picture taken.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Aah.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure it was
not in the laboratory.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah, yeah.
I mean this is a good example,
where it tells you so much.
It does.
Began with the names
and faces.
AUDIENCE: Books piled up
in the front of them.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: What's in the
books on the front?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Oh yeah, that's great.
So this is his dissertation in
German, from Breslau, three
years later.
He wrote it in Florence, because
he thought Florence
was the most beautiful city in
the world, and why not write
your dissertation there?
I recommend that highly,
if any of you write
dissertations.
But this is Germany.
And just keep that in mind when
we get to World War II.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: World War I.
PROFESSOR: And he was
sufficiently literate in
German to be able to write
a dissertation.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, he never felt his
German was that great.
And in fact, back to Latin, a
story he tells us taking the
train to Italy, or maybe
back from Italy.
But in any case, he was seated
next to somebody-- maybe they
were like Polish or something.
But German didn't work.
The other person didn't
know English.
So they conversed in Latin.
PROFESSOR: Is that right?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS:
You never know.
PROFESSOR: It's fascinating.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It
may come in handy.
So then he comes back to--
well, he has a year working
at a tannery in
Manchester, New Hampshire.
And as a result of that
experience, he always said
tanneries do not have
to pollute.
It's not necessary, if
you run them right.
And they don't have to smell
either, that's the other thing
you associate was a tannery.
So he comes back.
And you can see how chemical
engineering around 1910,
there's this kind of reversal
of who was majoring in what.
And this is before the war.
Because when World War I comes,
even before the US
enters World War I, the Great
War, in 1917, there's a
tremendous demand for
military equipment.
And chemical engineering is
connected with gas warfare,
which was used right near the
beginning of the war.
It was in the spring of 1915
that chlorine was first used
on the battlefield
as a poison gas.
Chlorine is not the most
effective, by any means.
It dissipates pretty quickly.
But the surprise factor was such
that it really did work
in the initial use.
And it had a tremendous
psychological effect in
scaring people on both sides.
So Walker, William Walker, was
put in charge of the Edgewood
Arsenal, once the US
entered the war, to
manufacture toxic gases.
And my grandfather was put
in charge of gas defense.
So he worked on the masks.
And there's all sorts of--
I mean this is very specialized
equipment.
And to try to design equipment
that made it possible to keep
fighting and yet would protect
the soldier from poison gas,
not just the soldier but--
do I have some of the--
the animals too.
In fact, there's a whole long
story about the horses being
affected by mustard gas,
which is a vesicant.
And it's a much nastier gas.
And it would affect
the animals too.
So the one story that I need
to tell you about my
grandfather and gas defense,
this made such an
impression on me.
We had this conversation
was I was a teenager.
Let's see, he said there was not
a single Allied soldier--
am I taking too much?
PROFESSOR: No, no.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It won't
take much longer.
There's not a single Allied
soldier is World War I who
died from poison gas when they
had the gas mask and other
equipment on.
And I grandpa, you must been so
proud because you designed
something that was fail-safe.
It worked every time.
And he said no, it means
I over designed.
And what he meant was the
cost of putting on a
mask is quite high.
It's makes it hard to breathe.
And it does encumber you.
So in designing the gas
mask, you have to make
it just on the edge.
Because then, soldiers are more
likely to put it on in
the first place.
So by over designing it, it
meant that he was surmising
that more people had died
but not putting
on the mask at all.
Because it was such
a pain to put on.
And for an engineer to think
that way about human life, it
just really took me aback.
And I thought, boy, that's
responsibility.
After he died in 1975, you clean
out the house of the
person who has passed on.
And down in the cellar, big
basement, in the furnace room
there are these shelves.
And there were all these gas
masks lined up on the shelves.
And it turned out at the end of
the war, the Allied troops
have given him a model of each
of the gas masks that had been
used by the Allies in the war.
So he had this collection of
gas masks that were just
sitting down there.
And I called the Smithsonian and
I called the MIT Museum,
and I said I think this
is really interesting.
But nobody took the gas masks.
So they have thrown out,
because I tried.
I tried.
AUDIENCE: You weren't tempted to
just mount them on wall in
your living room?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Well,
they're odd.
Well, I mean we'd been looking
at pictures from Japan,
testing children.
And when you get in a haz
suit, it's really scary.
It's just very curious,
period.
So no, I was not inclined
to keep them around.
I was just surprised somebody
didn't want them.
Well, actually now
I can go back to
gas masks for a minute.
You've read about the tension
between Noyes and Walker,
Walker finally leaving.
My grandfather finally becoming
head of the chemical
engineering department in 1920,
known as Walker's protege.
But also the real appreciation
for the science-based
engineering.
And the more I read Servos's
article, the more I would love
to look at his headship of
Course 10 in that period.
I think it's a really
interesting story.
I don't know it.
But I'm almost sure
it's there.
OK, he it comes back.
Heads the department for 10
years, but that isn't what he
wants to do.
He's not an administrative
type.
He doesn't like it.
He loves teaching and he's
famous for his teaching.
And that's where he really
made his mark.
But he did a lot of consulting
for what was what was then
Standard Oil in New Jersey,
Esso, Exxon.
And one thing your articles
didn't mention I think is the
relationship between the
university and industry
through consulting
work and how that
fits into the picture.
And he was a great believer in
the value of consulting.
That's how you find out what's
happening in the world and it
keeps you on your toes.
And it's also useful
for industry.
So he, to his death, he got a
check every month from Exxon.
I mean it wasn't a lot,
but it was a retainer.
And he died at what, 94.
So they were very loyal
to him and vice versa.
So this is a drawing of the
catalytic cracking process.
Let's see, have you been to
the MIT Museum exhibit?
You must have been.
AUDIENCE: I have.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: OK.
And you go through
the whole thing.
And just when you're going to
leave when to go out of the
exhibit in that back room, on
the left, is a picture of my
grandfather and a couple other
gentlemen at a refinery in
Venezuela where catalytic
cracking has been put into
production in 1939.
And there's a barrel
above there, an
empty barrel I trust.
But anyway, just to
make the exhibit
about catalytic cracking.
But the timing, 1939, means that
once the war broke out in
1940, the demand for aviation
fuel was huge.
I mean catalytic cracking began
as a way to get higher
octane for automobiles.
And it was the automobile
race that instigated it.
AUDIENCE: Does everybody know
what catalytic cracking is?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: So let me
give my brief, nontechnical--
actually this is very
interesting.
He did the work in the basement
of Building 12.
And you need some kind
of a catalytic agent
to promote the cracking.
It's usually a powder and its
mixed in with the petroleum to
get more higher octane fractions
or lighter weight
fractions out of a certain
amount of petroleum.
So if you have the same amount
of petroleum and the cracking
works efficiently, you get more
usable high octane fuel
than you do without it.
So you have this--
AUDIENCE: You take crude oil,
basically, and separating out
all the parts.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It's part of
the distillation process.
And a higher octane means you
can run engines faster and get
more power out of them, without
knocking and so forth.
You know when you need higher
octane, if you fill up your
car and your car starts
knocking.
That's a sign that things
are not going well.
It's true in cars.
It's true in airplanes.
So they were trying to blow
the catalyst through the
petroleum stream.
But as a pattern, it
kept settling out.
It didn't stay mixed
in with the stream.
So after months and months of
work, on trying to get it to
hold into the stream, my
grandfather, who was famously
profane, said damn it,
let it settle out.
And in other words, if you let
it settle out, then you get a
fluid bed at kind of the
bottom of the reactor.
And it mixes the fumes, the
petroleum fumes with, or
gases, with the catalyst, better
than if you try to blow
it along with the stream.
So it's fluid-bed catalytic
cracking that he and his
students are known for and
brought a huge fortune to
Exxon, which is one of
the early adopters.
What he never imagined
was that--
again, it comes on
line in 1939.
Within a year, the tankers are
going to Venezuela to fill up
with a high octane aviation
fuel, going to the docks of
Liverpool, and pumping
the fuel into
the tanks of Spitfires.
They don't even put it
in the holding tank.
They put it right in the
tanks of the airplanes.
And the Spitfires go
up to do battle in
the Battle of Britain.
So it's a dramatic example of
what you do and then how
things happen to change the
implications of what you do,
that are entirely out
of your control.
That of course is also
the story of
the Manhattan Project.
When the Manhattan Project
got under way--
do I have any slides
about this?
Oh, this goes back, OK--
basically my grandfather is
asked to head up the series of
committees making
recommendations about the
extraction and refinement
of fissionable material.
In other words, the chemical
engineering problems of the
atomic weapons, they require
high grade ore, high grade
uranium or plutonium.
And how do you get it?
That's an engineering problem.
That's a chemical engineering
problem.
So if you go to the MIT archives
and ask for Warren K.
Lewis material, a lot of it is
still classified from World
War II, but there is a notebook
that he kept when he
was going around to, trying
to figure out--
I think this is 1941.
When was the chain reaction
started? '42, right, in Stagg
Field, Chicago?
AUDIENCE: Chicago?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Chicago.
Was that earlier?
AUDIENCE: Earlier.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS:
It was earlier.
AUDIENCE: Before the
war I think.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: In the
middle of this notebook,
appears that event.
And he's going around to
DuPont, to Oak Ridge.
He's going out to Berkeley,
Lawrence Lab, talking to all
these people, trying to figure
out how to do the refining to
get the material that they would
need for these weapons.
And he served on a series
of committees.
Was gone all during the war,
kind of overseeing the
construction and the development
of these vast
facilities, especially at Oak
Ridge, also out in Hanford.
AUDIENCE: If you look at the
Manhattan Project, which my
favorite statistics would be
the size of the US auto
industry at the time, a huge
project, less that 10% of it
is concentrated at Los Alamos
or [INAUDIBLE].
Brilliant physicists are--
and most of it were chemical
engineering plants in
Tennessee and in Washington
state, huge plants making the
actual material.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: So he told
his wife, my grandmother, just
don't ask where I am.
But if you need me in an
emergency, you call General
Groves in Washington, and gave
her the phone number.
And again, I presume the
students have already heard
this, but my mother was
married in 1940 and
I was born in 1944.
So this was kind of
like the next
generation was coming along.
And my mother tells me that
when she heard the Lowell
Thomas announcement of the
bomb being dropped on
Hiroshima, on the radio, she
said now I know where pop's
been, all the war.
And I'm a baby.
And we're back to Japan
these days.
OK, I have to think he was
deeply troubled by his role in
the Manhattan Project because
he didn't talk about it.
He talked a lot about World
War I and gas masks.
But World War II, he just--
I mean I wish I had pressed
him more, but I didn't.
My mother said that
after the war--
for example, at those days if
you got a watch, a wrist
watch, and you wanted it to glow
in the dark, they put a
little radium on the dial just
to make it glow in the dark.
And he would scrape it off.
He didn't want any of
that stuff near him.
Anyway, so I'm surmising.
But he chaired the Lewis
committee, and you'll hear a
lot more about that, kept
teaching at MIT.
My husband had him as a kind
of senior thesis adviser in
the early 1960s.
And there's a lot of letters
that he wrote about the role
of the engineer and
civilization, the profession
of engineering.
And this quote from
the Lewis Report I
think really captures--
I mean we don't know who
actually wrote it.
Maybe it Morrison or somebody.
But he really believes that.
He said, if I could come back,
it would be as a social
scientist, because that's where
the big problems are,
the really intractable ones.
I can see after World War II
why you would say that.
So that's the--
yeah, the Spring Garden
farm again.
OK, so back to the farm.
So what I did in about 15
minutes before class was just
go through my box of stuff.
And I'm just going to
pass this around.
Obviously, just collect
it back there, when it
gets back to you.
The point is what you learn from
archives that you don't
learn from reading articles
or so forth.
Monthly Report, Laurel City
Schools, Laurel, Delaware,
Report of Warren Lewis, 1895.
This tells you sort of, not only
what his grades are, but
what they're teaching.
PROFESSOR: Is that the
original document?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: That's
the document.
Why do I have this stuff?
I have no idea.
I gave a lot of it
to the archives.
And they have copies of this.
And I kept a few original
documents.
There's a lot more.
I mean I am from a very
literate family.
I don't know how
else to put it.
Now Ross Basset told you about
going through MIT yearbooks
and looking at where
people are from?
PROFESSOR: A little bit.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: This is my
grandfather on the left.
So this is what Ross was looking
at, hometown and list.
My grandfather's list
is very brief.
But again, I just thought
you'd like to see.
And Breslau, here are
photographs of Breslau, where
he studied, got his Ph.D.
I mean it got bombed to
smithereens in the war.
None of this is here anymore.
But this is old Germany.
PROFESSOR: Did you ever go back
to try to visit there?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS:
Not Breslau, no.
I think it blew all
to smithereens.
PROFESSOR: Probably
nothing to see.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: And I had a
couple of bigger photos, that
are really beauties, that I
have framed it at home.
And here's his dissertation.
I'm not sure, my German
not being workable.
But it's signed Rosalind D.
Kenway, from Warren, July '05,
that's my grandmother.
The Tech, special chemistry
and chemical engineering
issue, 1910.
So remember that chart showing
chemistry is going down and
chemical-- so this is published
at that time.
I have no idea why I have
this, but I do.
And it's so interesting.
Few industries not founded
on chemistry, it says.
Now, this is a Xerox.
This is his father basically
selling off the stock of the
farm, public sale of
valuable cows.
And this is what his father
writes in 1917, back in
Laurel, Delaware.
I have sailed life's storm-swept
sea for 74 years
and I am now nearing port.
I smell the land.
It is wise that I should take
in-- and I can't read it.
But it must be take
in the sails--
Therefore on--
He's going to sell
his milk cows.
This is the start of the decline
of agriculture in the
United States right here,
the family farm.
This is the high school, now
Newton North, Newton high
school kind of review
magazine.
This is 1918.
A lot of young men are
going over to Europe.
But it talks about a Newton
high school scientist.
Of the many capable men on the
defense side of chemical
warfare service, perhaps none
has contributed more practical
ideas that Dr. Lewis.
This is his high school,
hall of fame, kind of.
This is page 10.
My kids went to the
same school.
PROFESSOR: Newton North?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS:
Yeah, of course.
OK, this is March 5, 1920.
PROFESSOR: Of course.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: You
got to show spirit.
PROFESSOR: Of course.
Boy if live in Newton,
there's a difference.
I know that.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: A
different Newton.
It matters whether it's
north or south.
OK, Debbie K. Lewis, required
Course 10, 1920.
His time here seems
very interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Well,
actually I won't pass this
around because he-- well,
maybe I will.
This is Spring Garden farm.
I showed you the photo
actually earlier.
OK, here we have-- oh look,
August 5, 1946.
Anybody know what happened
on August 5, 19--
you know what happened
on August 6, 1945?
It's Hiroshima.
A year minus a day later, James
R. Killian writes to Dr.
Compton, during the summer,
there have been a number of
discussions of the need to
promote here at the Institute,
more interest in the study of
educational objectives and
procedures.
This calls for the Lewis
Commission essentially.
And it's a letter saying
Lewis should head it.
And here's some people who
should be on it, and here's
the budget.
And then a second letter,
outlining in more detail what
the Lewis Commission would do.
It follows shortly thereafter.
Then I just have a bunch of,
again my grandfather's
thoughts about the history
of chemical engineering;
engineering as a profession; my
favorite title, "The Place
of Engineering in Society and
Civilization." This is from
Tech Review.
And I thought you would enjoy
this title, "Chemical
Engineering, A New Science,"
a new science, 1953.
And so these are all published
in one form or another.
But then there are letters.
And there are quite a few
letters to me, to my mother,
to my father, when my father's
trying to figure out-- this is
1945 and my father notes that
at GE, so many younger
engineers are getting offers
from small companies and
should be thinking about this?
And my grandfather writes
this long letter
back, in long hand.
In 1970, somebody has asked
him for conversations.
He wants to discuss the
fundamental differences
between Greek philosophy and
modern science on the purely
intellectual level.
And he wants me to come
up and help him write
something about this.
And this is very moving because
he says, I am getting
older and it's hard for people
to understand me.
You, however, have heard enough
of it over the years so
you know at least
the direction in
which my mind is working.
PROFESSOR: Ah, interesting.
High compliment.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah.
It's a huge compliment.
Anyway, if you don't get
the personality,
you're missing things.
Thanksgiving dinner.
Actually this would be 1963,
the fall of 1963.
So what happened in
the fall of 1963?
PROFESSOR: Oh, Kennedy.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It was
right after Kennedy's
assassination.
And my grandfather
is saying grace.
I remember this like
yesterday.
He had his usual grace and he
gave thanks for the American
family, because in such
difficult times like these,
that's the rock on which the
country is founded, the
American family.
This is my then boyfriend,
between me and my mother.
PROFESSOR: It's not Gary.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Yeah, yeah.
Have you see the actual
Lewis Report?
PROFESSOR: I have
never seen that.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It's nice,
nice binding job.
And this is A Dollar to a
Doughnut, which are stories
about my grandfather's
teaching.
And this is what the chemical
engineering department put
together for him when he retired
as a feitschrift,
because they felt the normal,
staid one was not appropriate
for such a character.
PROFESSOR: What year
did he retire?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Well, this
is the official retirement.
So this is like 1950 or so.
But as I say, he's like Leo.
He just kept teaching.
This is a CD.
Just so you know, in the
archives they have-- this is
from tape, the original
tape, now on CD.
At the 50th anniversary of the
Department of Chemical
Engineering, so in 1970,
he gave a talk about
reminiscences and the
fascinating history of
chemical engineering in the 19th
century, where he has a
whole theory about the time
lag between discovery and
implementation, both in
electrical and chemical
engineering.
For example, the role of
batteries in running the
telegraph system, which I had
never thought about it as an
incentive to chemical
engineering.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Oh,
very interesting.
AUDIENCE: You know the great
mentors of the chemical
industry that got [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Paper making.
A lot of early involvement.
[INAUDIBLE]
to some degree, much less than
they were a national center of
paper making.
A lot of the early MIT chemical
engineers were with
the paper industry.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: I
didn't know that.
And this last thing, and I
bring this along just in
serendipity.
This is an obituary in 1975.
He died on March 9.
This is the Tech Talk,
when we used to have
a printed MIT newspaper.
But what struck me
as I was picking
it up, OK, an obituary.
And then I look on the back of
the first page, "Response
Awaited on Proposal to Train
Iranian Nuclear Engineers."
And it just struck me, this
is why I love hard copy.
Because you' come across
things you don't
plan to come across.
And this is a reminder
of this is happening.
And of course this had my
attention, but on the back we
were being friendly with Iran.
The Shah was still around.
OK.
So that's my show and tell.
Do you have any questions?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Thank you for bringing
all this stuff.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Well,
I just love stuff.
PROFESSOR: It reminds me that
I think historians have a
special feeling for
stuff like this.
But I remember when I was
working on my dissertation at
the National Archives, I was
writing about a topic that
dated back to the end
of the War of 1812.
So it was a long time ago.
And I was getting materials out
of the archives that were
still bound in the original
red tape.
And you'd pull those strings
apart and they would
disintegrate.
I don't know, it's a weird
feeling thinking that I'm the
first one to look at the stuff
in over 200 years.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: It's kind
of creepy, but it's also
exhilarating.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it is.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Exploration,
right.
PROFESSOR: And then we had a
colleague that Ros and I knew,
and I think you may have
known him too, David.
His name was Brooke Hindle.
He was the former director of
the Museum of American History
at the Smithsonian.
But he wrote an article one time
called "What is a Piece
of the True Cross Worth." Do
you remember that article,
about the importance of
artifacts in the study of
technology particularly?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: The story
is that they had four
children, two daughters,
two sons.
The other daughter, besides my
mother, Mary, married a guy
named Cherry Emerson, who
went into plastics
after World War II.
Plastics, and to quote Chambers,
made quite a bit of
money in chemical engineering.
And he studied with Doc
during the war.
So he gave the money to renovate
the library, naming
it in honor of my grandmother,
Warren K Lewis' wife.
And he always claimed
it was because she
loved music so much.
And I must say I never
heard her listen
or talk about music.
So I think it was more
Cherry's love
of music, than her's.
But that doesn't matter.
I think it's a great library.
And I think my grandmother would
particularly be happy
that students can sleep
on the couches there.
She's a very gentle soul.
AUDIENCE: Does anybody here have
parents who went to MIT
or other relatives?
So one think you do see is,
any institution that lasts
this long has this kind
of family connection.
Universities are sort of famous
for keeping track of
that sort of thig.
And that's true among
faculty, as well.
And there's the genealogies
of our blood families.
And then we'll talk a bit about
this, but not to much
explicitly yet.
We'll talk about it in the
second half, the academic
genealogies of so and so's
teacher was so and so's
student, was so and
so's student,
was so and so's student.
And then our colleague, Leo
Marx, who was my teacher, Who
said that, how does it go?
His adviser from Harvard in the
'40s-- it's only two steps
back to Ralph Waldo Emerson.
You can trace four academic
generations today from Leo
Marx to Ralph Waldo Emerson.
I'm sure there are people
here, some of the senior
faculty who were students
of your grandfather's.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: If
I go to Chemical
Engineering, they just--
oh, Warren K--
AUDIENCE: And that's a person
who started here in 1896.
And more than 100 years later,
there are still that person's
students around.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: That's been
a great been pleasure of
university life.
It's a sense of continuity.
I mean it would drive
me crazy too.
PROFESSOR: Ros, your grandfather
was born in
Delaware and pretty
much raised there.
He obviously was a
religious person.
What persuasion?
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: I think in
Delaware, he was Methodist.
PROFESSOR: Methodist.
Yeah, that makes sense.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: And one of
the most fascinating books I
have is of an uncle of his who
was a Methodist circuit rider
in Delaware, in the 1850s,
setting up black churches.
They were separate,--
PROFESSOR: Really.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: --but
setting them up.
Oh, it's fascinating.
And my grandfather then joined
the Congregational church up
here, Elliott church
in Newton.
Because Methodism up here is a
little different from what it
was in the South.
But you get the point.
It's a low church.
It's not Episcopalian.
And he taught Sunday school
every Sunday,
as long as he could.
And his religious faith
meant a lot to him.
He was not a fundamentalist,
at all.
He said, I take the Bible
seriously, but not literally.
But I mean he knew his
Bible up one side
and down the other.
And it was really fundamental
to him.
In his old age, he became good
friends with John Crocker, who
was the Episcopal chaplain
here at MIT.
And they had a lot of talks.
And I mean again, I think maybe
whether it was guilt
about the Manhattan Project or
just trying to kind of talk
about matters of faith and
other matters too.
So Crocker led his funeral
service, which I was glad that
he was able to do.
So I think religion is one of
the great untapped kind of
untapped, unappreciated sources
of motivation at MIT.
And I don't think my
grandfather's unusual.
And it's not necessarily any
particular religion.
But people from outside MIT are
always amazed to find how
strong the religious groups are
here and how many there
are and how active they are.
It's not their vision of MIT,
but it's very true.
OK.
ROSALIND WILLIAMS: Well,
thank you very much.
PROFESSOR: Thank
you very much.
PROFESSOR: OK, I want to just
talk today a little bit more
about the '30s, the
'20s and the '30s.
And again, kind of like Ros's
talk, use a specific case of a
particular faculty member and
a particular machine to
illustrate some of the general
ideas about where MIT moved
between about 1925 and 1935 and
why that's interesting.
And you of course know from the
readings, and the more you
look at this, everybody says it
and the more I read about
it, the more you really feel
like Karl Compton coming here
in 1930 was a major
turning point.
There was this kind of
internal warfare.
What was the word that Lewis
used, hot fights about the
relation of science
and engineering.
And the Corporation definitely
has an opinion about it.
And one thing they do--
they don't have a lot of control
over the faculty, but
they do decide who
the president is.
And so they bring
in Karl Compton.
He's 42 years old--
and it probably sounds
old to you.
It sounds young to me--
in 1930.
And one of the young people who
was already here was this
guy then Vannevar Bush, who
we've also heard about, and
we'll hear about a bunch more,
who was a young electrical
engineering professor.
And he was building this
device called a
differential analyzer.
And what I want to do today--
this is again, a sort of
prototype for what a paper topic
might be, is to look at
this instrument and how this
instrument was handled and how
the instrument itself changed
as the goals of the
Institution changed, from the
'20s through the '30s.
So here's Bush and there's
the analyzer.
And when we go to the MIT
Museum, one of the 150 objects
is that part of the
analyzer that's in
the wooden box there.
I'll tell you more about
what that is.
But it's sitting right there
on the front of the floor.
And when I was first doing this
research, I asked them if
they had a piece of it and
they didn't really know.
And Debbie Douglas and I went
back in the storerooms and we
found that the original
integrator was there.
So if you go into the
1920s, Bush is here.
He's a young professor.
He had gotten his Ph.D. here.
And he was a student of
Kennelly, who I mentioned
before, who was Edison's
assistant.
And they were very much in the
kind of technology plan world
of MIT, solving problems for
big industrial partners.
And what is the problem that
the big industrial partners
are having?
Well, in the electrical world,
and you've got to remember
electrical engineering for a--
how people here are Core 6,
in one way or another?
OK, so about a third.
Electrical engineering, for its
first 100 years, really
was electrical, without a lot of
electronics or any of that
solid state physics
or certainly no
computers and stuff.
It was building big machines
to make big generators, and
big generators, transmission
lines, large electric motors,
to drive factories and other
kinds of things.
And anybody ever hear of the
IEEE, Institute of Electrical
and Electronic Engineers?
This is a little
bit of trivia.
But there was the AIEE,
American Institute of
Electrical Engineers.
Those are the big electric
power people.
In fact, in German universities
they still divide
the curriculum into big signals
and a little signals.
And so big signals
was the AIEE.
Little signals was the IRE,
Institute of Radio
Engineering, lots of little
tiny, little small signals.
And in 1964, they merged
in the IEEE.
It's to electrical and
electronic engineers.
Even though it's probably one of
the two major professional
societies for computation, but
the word "computer" doesn't
appear in the title at all.
And so, this is back in the
days of electric power.
And the problem with the
electric power industry is the
electric generators start out as
basically local phenomena.
A local entrepreneur will build
a generator, either a
hydro plant or steam powered,
in one way or
another, in a town.
And they'll create lighting in
the town and maybe run some
motors in factories.
And it's all centralized and
it was all nonuniform.
Every town had a different
voltage, a different frequency.
Some of them were running
on direct current versus
alternating current.
These are all big battles they
were having at the time.
But over the course of the
teens and the '20s, those
systems are becoming
standardized and they're
becoming connected into what
today we would call grids.
So they have a big electric
power grid.
And they're not quite
national yet, but
they're very much regional.
And so in the '20s, General
Electric starts to build a big
grid that brings hydroelectric
power from in Canada and also
from Niagara Falls, through
very, very long transmission
lines, hundreds and hundreds
of miles, down into the New
York City area, which is where
most of the population and
most of the energy
usage is from.
And those lines begin
to have problems.
And the problems are, if you've
got either a lightning
strike at one part of the line,
you had a bad electrical
storm, or even if you had a
short circuit and part of the
grid tripped off and had just to
sort of save itself, you'd
get these transients
on the line.
And the transients would
travel great distances.
They were just like big wave
power spikes on the line and
create blackouts all
over the place.
And there a couple of famous
blackouts that happened in the
early '20s that really
caused a big problem.
So this was like a critical
issue about how do you figure
out, how do you model the
performance of these systems
under this kind of stress?
And General Electric, and this
has come up in the readings in
places, had a very close
relationship with MIT.
There were a lot of young
engineers who would go there,
what they called on-test,
to Schenectady.
In fact, that's where
Ros's father worked.
I don't if she mention that,
Doc Lewis's son went to
Schenectady and worked
for General Electric.
And then they would come back
to MIT sometimes, to get a
master's degree.
And they began looking at this
problem of how do you
understand these systems.
Now, Bush had done earlier work
in his career, which was
also based on this whole
idea of modeling.
I may have mentioned
this before where--
how many of you have taken an
engineering class where you
use a spring mass damper
system and model a RLC
circuit with it?
Ring a bell for anybody?
OK, maybe a few too
many times.
Or, there are other analogies,
different kinds
of hydraulic analogies.
Well, that whole idea basically
comes from the first
book that Vannevar Bush wrote,
which is called Operational
Circuit Analysis, where first
of all he applies a thing
called Oliver Heaviside's
operational calculus.
Anybody ever heard of the
Heaviside step function?
And Heaviside was a sort of
somewhat outlandish English
engineer around the turn of the
century, who came up with
these ideas.
Mathematicians didn't like them
because they couldn't
prove they were valid.
Heaviside just didn't care about
it at all because he
could show that they
were useful.
And they told you a lot about
how transients go down lines.
And Bush really took the
Heaviside work and he put it
on a rigorous mathematical
foundation.
And said among other things,
you can use these analogies
and you can model a second order
system in any of these
different fields with
a set of equations.
And that can be either RLC
circuit or a spring mass
damper or there are also
hydraulic versions of it, I'm
sure any number of other ones.
And what that basic idea allows
you to do is to make
models of different
kinds of circuits.
And so what they said
is here's this
electric power problem.
Let's look at this problem and
let's build a model of it.
And what this thing is, is
called a network analyzer.
And this picture is probably
about 1927.
And all it is, is-- well, first
thing they make a model
of just the electric
power line between
Niagara Falls and Boston.
So there might be a couple of
generators on the line in
Niagara Falls, then there's a
long transmission line, then
there's a whole bunch of
different users, and maybe you
make one circuit that's
50,000 times
smaller than the original.
And you use that as a model.
And anybody know what
the big problem
with that was actually?
The hardest thing about making
these small models was
measuring the output.
If you go to the actual electric
power system and you
put a voltmeter on the line,
that voltmeter is going to
load the line by some amount.
But it's negligible, it
really has no impact.
If you make it 50,000 times
smaller, you've still got the
same voltmeter.
And you put it on the line and
it's the equivalent of like
putting a whole factory
on the line.
And it affects the performance
of it in ways
that it wouldn't otherwise.
So it's one thing to
make this model.
And they did that rather
successfully and it helped
them describe.
And they then reported the
results to GE, this is how the
thing would behave under
a lightning strike.
And these are some strategies
you can take to make it a
little more robust.
Well, once the word out about
that, all these different
power companies came and
said, we would like you
to model our system.
And so what did they do?
Did they constantly build
a new one for
everybody's power system?
No.
They built a little set up.
Actually, I don't even have to
draw it, because it's here.
Where they said OK, we're going
to put a bunch of models
of transmission lines and a
bunch of models of generators
and a bunch of models
of other things.
And they're actually connected
together by
telephone plug boards.
And you bring your system here
and we'll plug it together in
a certain way, much
like a telephone
operator connects circuits.
At that time, it was
done manually.
And we'll create this thing.
And this thing, they actually
called it a network computer,
which is a nice word for it,
that comes up later in MIT
culture, about 50 years later.
And electric power companies
would come here.
And students would write their
theses by designing this
system and describing it for
a particular power company.
And saying here, I modeled
your circuit.
And this thing actually
was around until the
'50s, it turns out.
We'll talk about it getting shut
down when Gordon Brown
shut it down.
But it was again this kind of
classic MIT in the 1920s,
early '30s, model of close
relationships with industry,
solving very particular
problems, almost in a literal
consulting role.
Tell us what your issue is?
We'll model it and we'll help
you solve the problem.
So we read a lot about that.
Then there was another approach,
which was to
calculate the progress of these
transients directly.
And how did they do that?
Well, they could do it
analytically with algebra.
It was extremely difficult
because it was not easy to
write the equations.
But it was much easier
to build an analog
computer to model it.
And it turned out, and you
probably recognize this, that
the integral of the product
of two functions
is a critical piece.
Today, you find it in all kinds
of signals processing
and convolution algorithms.
And they said we'll build
basically these machines that
will model the key
function of it.
And this is an early version
of it, which is also a
specific machine modeled
to evaluate
the specific integral.
They called it a product
intergraph.
And it didn't use equations
at all.
It just took curves in
and drew curves out.
There you can see Bush.
This is actually the output
device, which
is a watt/hour meter.
Why would they use
a watt/hour meter
from an electric utility?
Because a watt/hour meter does
the same thing, right.
It evaluates the integral of
the product of the current.
And the voltage is the
amount of power that
you get billed for.
So they take this thing and
they just stick there.
And then there's these kind of
funky mechanical linkages.
And there's all these
people involved.
And actually they have
big high-power
resistors, so they use a--
anybody want to guess what
that thing hanging
up on the top is?
AUDIENCE: Radiator.
PROFESSOR: Close.
PROFESSOR: It's a
radiator, from?
AUDIENCE: Model T.
PROFESSOR: It's a radiator
from a Model T Ford, that
they're using to provide cooling
water to this machine,
which evaluates this particular
integral for this
particular electric
power problem.
In fact, some of these
are Bush's students.
This one particularly is a guy
named Harold Hazen, who we
will talk about later.
In fact, he's also the guy
sitting in the middle there,
in that picture.
Here's another picture of it.
You can see the watt/hour meter,
just taken right out of
an electric power measurement
facility.
Again, you sort of work
with what you have.
They were working with
electric companies.
They had these electrical
things, a whole bunch of
different motor and gears
and interconnections.
And this was probably
in Building--
somewhere in the main group.
I'm forgetting exactly.
Building 10, I believe
was this lab.
I liked, you still have the
pencil sharpener there.
This is probably the one part
of what was in the lab that
you might still find in
a laboratory today.
There's a picture
of Bush with it.
You can see he looks
pretty young.
And so there's the
first product
intergraph, is this device.
And what it does is all those
little graph chart holders
basically, move under these
three independent needles.
And the operators just follow
the first two curves and then
the output plots the integral
of those two curves.
So it's literally a graphical
user interface
for an analog computer.
And then, they actually bring
it up to one more level of
complication.
And there's a way that you can
make it solve a differential
equation, as well as just
evaluating an integral.
And so this thing is called the
second product intergraph,
where it's the same
kind of thing.
There's two different pieces and
then you can sort of tie
the output back to the input.
And this is about where things
stood when Karl Compton
becomes president of MIT.
And Compton basically says,
we're not going to do that
kind of stuff anymore.
It's too focused on
just one problem.
It's too simple.
And Bush responds in a
very energetic way.
And he builds this machine
about 1931.
And this is called the
differential analyzer.
Anybody ever heard of
that term before?
And really it's kind of nothing
more than this, but
made in a fully general
purpose way.
Or like I mentioned before, they
did with the simulator,
they first started building a
custom one and then they built
a general one.
And what you see here is, these
guys here are called
integrators.
That's the core of
the problem.
Again, it's primarily an
integral thing you're trying
to evaluate.
An integrator is nothing more
than, they call it a wheel and
disk integrator.
There's a disk that
spins around.
In a mechanical sense, that's
just a transmission, but a
continuously variable one.
Then there's a wheel that sits
on the transmission.
And if the disk is spinning at
a fixed rate and the wheel
goes in and out, the number of
turns on the upper end of
wheel is the integral of the
curve of the position of the
wheel that pulls it off.
But it's a very simple idea
mechanically, very hard to do
that in a way that
is mechanically
robust and very accurate.
And that's the piece--
actually it was so critical to
make it accurate, they covered
these with those wooden boxes.
That's the piece that's
in the MIT Museum.
And then there's all these
other elements.
I may have a picture of it.
So there are all these
other elements.
You can take these integrators
and then you have a
multiplier, which is nothing but
a gear that connects one
rod to another in a ratio.
And you have these rods that
go through the middle.
They're almost like the
bus on a computer.
And you can connect these things
in all different ways
to evaluate a particular
equation.
In this case, this is just a
second order equation for a
falling body problem.
But you can mix and match this
thing and essentially program
it by rebuilding it around
these connecting rods.
And so, I'll show you a couple
of pictures of the--
oops.
Here is another view
of the integrator.
Here you can see the
disk and the little
wheel that takes off.
It actually has a real
knife edge on it, to
try to make it accurate.
One of the real problems with
those integrators is that they
can't drive much of a load.
If they slip at all, they
lose a lot of accuracy.
So here they have put these
things called torque
amplifiers, which are these very
clunky, exotic, kind of
cached in like devices that
amplify the torque.
And then they connect them in.
And where you might have in an
electrical analog computer,
there's a voltage that gets
pushed around, in a mechanical
analogue computer it's just the
rotation of these shafts
that carry the data from
one place to another.
And they do that by going into
this matrix of mechanical rods
that you see over there
on the left.
And each time they wanted, they
could kind of reprogram
the whole thing.
And here's another shot.
So here's a gear ratio that
would perform the
multiplication.
You can see that this stuff is
beautifully machined, very
interesting and carefully
done.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And they were doing
this in the electrical
department.
PROFESSOR: This is in electrical
engineering
department, right.
AUDIENCE: It seems very much
like a mechanical project.
PROFESSOR: It does seem like
a mechanical project.
That's a very good point.
And Bush actually said, he was
very clear, he said, I want my
engineers to be able to design
mathematical equations the way
they design circuits.
And he tried to make a
circuit design-type
language, visual language--
I redrew this picture.
But I redrew it from one
of their papers.
It's the same terminology--
that you could actually design
these equations and make these
big kind of systems.
And already you're beginning
to see a move toward
generality.
So he says, this is not a device
to evaluate integrals
for studying transience in the
electric power industry.
This is a research device
for a general
purpose calculating machine.
And it's interesting, he goes
to the Rockefeller--
well, I'll cover that
in a minute.
So already you're beginning to
see this guy beginning to
think in a more general, kind
of fundamental terms, as
opposed to in these
specific terms.
And this is within just a couple
of years of Compton
coming here to MIT.
Here's the output
of the device.
You can see it's basically
creating a family of curves.
And they were very into
the fact that they
didn't need any algebra.
They didn't need
any equations.
They said the world is
basically analog.
They didn't use that term.
And said, the world
is continuous.
Our integrator is
continuous and
produces continuous outputs.
And again, you can
see this kind of
graphical user interface.
There's a little magnifying
glass there.
And he's kind of following these
curves, which was a kind
of manual input.
Bush is kind of looking over
the shoulder there.
And they would evaluate
all these
different kinds of curves.
Here's another view, where
they're all connected by an
electrical audio system.
And there's one guy in the
center, telling everybody OK,
follow your curves now.
And here, he's not doing it
by hand so much anymore.
He's turning a little crank
to trace all the curves.
And you can begin to see by the
curves, they can do some
pretty complicated things.
And there's a whole kind of
science of analog computing
that comes up in the '30s around
these machines, where
they measure the number of
integrators the way you would
measure the number of megahertz
of processor that
you have in your computer.
Because the integrator was the
expensive thing that kind of
described what order equation
you could possibly model with
these things.
And people start to use them
to model electron orbits in
atomic physics.
They used them particularly
for ballistics.
The Army gets really
interested.
And they have to calculate
ballistic equations for all
different kinds of
guns and shells.
And this makes it a lot
more convenient.
And so you begin to see the move
away from, even with the
same research group, the same
people literally, from this
kind of specific industry
oriented work toward more
general work in what
they think of as a
general purpose computing.
This is kind of the most famous
picture of the device.
And you can see there
three integrators
inside their glass cases.
Those integrated became so
precise that you had to have
them covered, free of dust, and
really very well protected.
And it turns out there was a
integrator that was developed
secretly by the Navy for
controlling the big guns on
battleships, that was better
than this one, that they
weren't really aware yet.
And has nobody ever see
a tubal integrator?
It's a whole other kind of
mechanism that you can use to
do mechanical integration.
So then this project spurs a
whole bunch of different other
kinds of projects.
One is called the cinema
intergraph, where the idea is
instead of integrating with
these kind of problematic
mechanical integrators, you
integrate using this exotic
new technology.
Anybody want to guess what
that is over on the left?
It's a photo cell.
And they would actually plot
the mathematical curves as
images on this 35
millimeter film.
And then shine a light through
it and plot the area under the
curves by integrating the charge
that came through the
photo cell.
And this is the guy
who made it.
As he said, it was mostly
a machine for producing
dissertations.
It had essentially no
practical output.
But it was important in that,
this guy is named Gordon
Brown, who is a student of
Harold Hazen, and becomes the
dean of engineering right
at the end of the
Second World War.
And is the guy who closes down
all that old-fashioned
electrical machinery.
We read about him
a little bit.
I think it was in the
[? Laquier ?]
article.
And kind of is the dean of
engineering when they kind of
formalized a lot of things after
the Second World War.
And there's another picture
of the cinema intergraph.
Also one of his advisers on
there was Norbert Wiener, who
was also very closely related
to Bush's work.
And a lot of his earlier ideas
of cybernetics also came out
of this work.
This is Harold Hazen again.
It's called an automatic
curve follower.
And his idea is, gee, maybe I
could make these photo cells
just follow these curves
automatically.
And today, you can go to the
Science Museum and buy a
little robot kit with a
robot that follows a
line across the floor.
This is the first
one of those.
But what's much more interesting
and important than
that about this, was that in
order to do this and order to
make the differential analyzer
work, it's the amount of
friction that builds up
in the mechanisms.
And it gets to a point where you
basically just can't turn
the crank anymore.
And you start to lose
a lot of accuracy.
You don't lose it
in the gears.
Eventually you would, because
they would break.
But you lose it in all these
other systems, particularly
the integrator.
So what they do is they put what
they call followers or
servomechanisms between the
stages, where they can kind of
renew the signal and add
energy to the system.
Because with a mechanical
system, if you don't have any
energy, it's just going
to eventually--
the energy is all dissipated.
But if you can carry the data
from one point to another and
just add energy and make it
constantly stronger, you can
build them as big as you want.
And it's between that problem
and this problem that Hazen
actually writes the first paper
ever on what he calls
the theory of servomechanisms,
which you now what know as
feedback control theory.
And anybody take a course on
that, or probably in every
engineering course you're taking
something in feedback
control theory.
And he became interested in
these basic problems.
Until that point, people had
governors on steam engines.
They had different kinds of
regulators in this electric
power network they
were working on.
But nobody had thought of, let's
write about the theory
of how this feedback mechanism
works overall.
And there again, there's another
one of these, a little
more detailed example of an
intellectual way that
Compton's move was not just
administrative, he didn't just
say let's stop working
with industry
and think about science.
He actually influenced these
people in their labs very
quickly, within a couple years,
to start thinking about
fundamental problems as opposed
to just these kind of
immediate problems.
Hazen also becomes dean of
engineering at MIT during the
Second World War and head of
the electrical engineering
department.
Here's his model of
servomechanisms.
Also in that group, looking at
again this electric power
problem, and saw something
literally in the electrical
power problem that was
bigger than simply
the immediate problem.
Anybody want to get
who this is?
Let me describe what
he's doing and
maybe then you'll guess?
So you can actually see in this
picture, he says, I'm
going to look at these
generators.
And the problem is when
they have these
transients of these--
they fall out of step, so that
in an A/C system, everything
has to be running in
perfect synchrony.
And if it's not running
synchronized, you get all
kinds of issues.
And he says, I'm going to tape
cardboard N and S. So that I'm
going to tape them to each of
the poles on the generator and
then let the generator
spin really fast.
And then I'm going to shine a
light on it and I'm going to
pulse the light at exactly
the same frequency as the
generator is supposed
to be spinning.
And that will freeze the
N and S in your eye
when you look at it.
And then if there's a phasing
problem, you'll see the N and
the S moving back and forth.
Now, anybody want to
guess who this is?
AUDIENCE: Edgerton.
PROFESSOR: This is
Edgerton, right?
And this is the first
application he have of this
stroboscope.
And very soon, he says hey,
you know what, this
stroboscope thing is
really interesting.
I can make some innovations
there.
Forget about electric
power stuff.
I'm interested in high-speed
photography and generally
high-speed electrical
discharge.
AUDIENCE: It's like the first
timing light for a car.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's exactly the same as the
timing light for a car.
Most of which are made
by EG&G, which
was Edgerton's company.
And so there again, he gets
interested in a bunch of
different things.
But all of them have in common
this idea of like how even
most of the flashes--
you don't see it so much in your
digital camera, with the
little teeny ones.
But if you ever have a big
flash, it fires and then you
hear it charging up.
And then it fires all again.
And Edgerton really became an
expert at very rapid discharge
of electrical energy.
I work a lot at the Undersea
World, where Edgerton did a
lot of work with sonar.
But the particular kind of sonar
he built was very much
like the flash bulb, in
that it was a sonar
that flashed the sound.
It's called side-scan sonar,
rather than continuous wave
sonar, would just gave
it all the time.
So for the plutonium bomb in
particular, the one during
World War II, and I think they
still are spherical, and you
had to implode this device.
And a guy at Harvard,
Kistiakowsky, made these
explosive lenses.
And you had to trigger them
all around this sphere at
exactly the same moment.
Otherwise, you were going to get
a lopsided shock wave and
you weren't going to implode
the thing perfectly.
And it was Edgerton's company
that designed the triggering
mechanisms for that
atomic bomb.
They also did high-speed
photography of the actual
mushroom clouds.
And it's amazing, sort of
frightening imagery that
they've collected all through
the Cold War about that.
And that was EG&G. It was
founded by Edgerton,
Germeshausen, and Grier,
two of his colleagues.
And the-- let's see,
what is it--
Building 37 is the building
they gave.
And there's a Grier room and
the Germeshausen room.
And I forget which the
auditorium is called.
But that work started here.
And then Edgerton
developed that.
And interestingly, one of the
students, a guy named Marty
Klein, who is the sort of the
father of that side-scan
sonar, is a good
friend of mine.
And he always says, Edgerton
was a time domain man.
He never thought in the
frequency domain.
For those of you who are
EEs, you'll know
what that refers to.
And that really came out this
legacy from Bush's lab of
thinking about transience
on these lines.
There's nothing to say about
electric power systems in the
frequency domain, because
it's all 60 Hertz.
It's all exactly the same
frequency, unlike radio which
is all about frequency domain.
He thought in the time domain.
And everything about
the electronics--
anybody work in the Edgerton
lab these days or
take a class there?
All that stuff is time domain
stuff, kind of epitomized by
the high-speed photography.
Here's an image again of the
Army getting interested at the
Aberdeen Proving Ground, down
in Maryland, which did a lot
of the measurement
for ballistics.
They bought five or six of these
or they hired people and
they made their own
copies of them.
Within a few years, during the
'30s, they were all over the
place, not just in
electric power.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When do you begin
to see military
funding of this work?
Does it start with Bush's
differential?
No, OK.
PROFESSOR: Really not
until the war.
So I'll come to the funding
issue in a second, because
it's pretty interesting.
They also, with Bush's
consulting, built the control
system for the Palomar
telescope, which at the time
was the biggest telescope
ever built.
It didn't even become
operational until after the
Second World War.
Anybody ever been there?
It's in California, outside
of San Diego.
And you have this enormous,
three-story high telescope.
And you've got to point it
with great accuracy.
And it actually had a lot of
similarities to the problems
they were working on there.
So there's also a funding
story here.
Warren Weaver is also
mentioned in the--
I'm forgetting if it was the
Servos or the [? Laquier ?]
article from the Rockefeller
Foundation.
And they talk about it.
It was [? Laquier. ?]
He said, as soon as Compton
came in, he went to the
Rockefeller Foundation and said,
I need $175,000 for this
new initiative.
And if you guys back
me on this--
at the time, there was no
National Science Foundation.
There was no public money other
than from the military,
available for research.
But the Rockefeller Foundation
was basically the equivalent
of the NSF today, a
private foundation
handing out these checks.
And Bush went to Weaver.
And he went to Weaver with
this early version of the
differential analyzer.
And it was about 1931.
And Weaver says,
not interested.
That engineering stuff is best
handled by industrial funding.
We don't support anything
that looks
like engineering research.
We only support fundamental
research.
Why don't you go find an
electric power company or
somebody to give it to you?
Two years later, Bush goes back
to Weaver and says oh,
this is not a machine for
electric power research.
This is a machine for
fundamental research in computing.
And Weaver says, oh, well if
you're going to put it that
way, here's $100,000.
At the depths of the Depression,
that a lot of
money for a research program,
far beyond what anybody-- in
fact, I think there's a
statistic in there that before
the war, the entire federal
funding for all of MIT was
only $40,000 a year.
And they gave Bush, not just
$100,000, but about $250,000
in the middle of the '30s, to
build the next version, which
became known as the Rockefeller
differential analyzer.
And here you see, it looks a
little bit more sophisticated.
Instead of those earlier tables,
they called them input
tables, here you have
a rotating drum.
There's still a person required
to sit there and turn
the handle.
But the basic model was
a lot more electrical.
And also interestingly, the
operators of these machines
changed from men to women.
So they're no longer graduate
students operating them.
They're much more what they
called human computers at the
time, operating them.
But you can see there,
a similar idea.
There are curves on this drum.
The person looks at the curves
and is providing the input to
the machine by matching the
pointer to the curve.
And the way this machine
worked, is also really
interesting.
A lot like the other one, but
instead of that matrix of
circular rods in the middle,
it's a crossbar switch.
Anybody know what industry a
crossbar switch comes from?
It's a telephone switch.
And its electrical switch that
basically says, I got all
these inputs across the top and
all these inputs across
the bottom.
I can connect anyone to anyone,
in fact in this case
using a punched paper tape.
And so they get the
prototype crossbar
switch from Bell Labs.
It was a pretty big revolution
in telephone
switching at the time.
They had built this crossbar
and donated it to MIT.
And what they did was they
said, we're just going to
adapt each of these mechanical
elements-- in fact, the
integrators were still
mechanical--
but we're going to give them
electrical outputs.
Instead of the quantities
being represented by the
rotation angle of the
rod, it's now
represented by a voltage.
We'll feed all the voltages
into the crossbar switch.
And then you configure the
crossbar switch by reading a
paper tape into it.
And so you can basically model
any equation by some set of
switch closings on the crossbar
switch and you
program those by a paper tape.
And now, you're beginning to see
the beginning of digital
switching coming into -- there
wasn't even a word for
"digital" at the time--
coming into this idea of
analogue computing.
And so then the problem for the
programmer becomes, they
have this continuous analog
equation across the top.
I need to translate it into
these paper tapes.
And that's kind of an
interesting problem, how do I
think about the transformation
from a set of equations into a
set of switch closures?
And this young master student
looks at it and he says well,
I can actually make
this kind of--
he calls it a relay algebra.
And I'm going to design a little
kind of mechanical
notation that will allow me
to design these circuits.
And you know that totally
useless stuff that I studied
in mathematics they called
Boolean algebra, from the 19th
century, is actually kind
of useful here.
And I'm going to call a closed
switch, a 1 and an open
switch, a 0.
And that allows you to
manipulate the whole thing
mathematically.
Anybody know who this is?
You maybe the name flash by.
AUDIENCE: You mean
Claude Shannon?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's actually
Claude Shannon, writes his
master's thesis on exactly
this problem.
And many people call this the
most significant master's
thesis ever written in
electrical engineering.
The master's thesis basically
lays down the entire
groundwork for the design of
digital systems in 1936 and
based on the problems that are
raised by designing this
computational machine.
And he immediately gets hired by
Bell Labs and starts to go
work there and think about how
to design switching circuits.
And the kind of counterpart at
Bell Labs right at that moment
reads this thesis and says, I'm
going to call this kind of
electronics digital.
And actually invents the word
"digital" to describe that
kind of electronics.
So here's a case of--
again, 1936, Karl Compton
has only been
at MIT for six years.
But he's already pushed this
particular laboratory and this
particular set of students to
start thinking about their
work in a different way.
Much less specific to one
industry specific to solving
particular applications, and
more generally thinking about
the fundamentals, the
mathematics, with applications
to lots and lots
of other areas.
So that's just one case there,
I thought I would show you.
And then, all those people are
also then people who get very
involved in the early
digital computing.
Once the war starts, basically
they all go to
Washington with Bush.
Some of them stay here and
get very involved.
But we'll cover that in the next
time we actually meet.
Questions, comments
about that?
AUDIENCE: Is that the same
servomechanism laboratory that
goes and creates
the Whirlwind?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The earlier question, it's
exactly that laboratory.
So Gordon Brown starts
the Servomechanism
Laboratory in 1940.
He the first course ever
on feedback control
theory at MIT in 1939.
And he writes this one paper.
In fact, it's called "Transient
Analysis of
Servomechanisms." So it still
carries that transient idea
from the early electric
power work.
And Warren Weaver shows up in
his lab and says, guess what?
I work for the government now.
I don't work for the
Rockefeller Foundation anymore.
That paper that you just wrote,
that you're about to
publish, it's classified.
You're not allowed to
publish it anymore.
And here's $500,000
to start your lab.
And Brown sort of takes it in.
And if it happens for an
historian, very valuable that
they classified that paper.
Because then, anyone who
got a copy of it,
had to sign it out.
So he writes this fundamental
paper.
And then you can actually trace
week by week, out in the
community, who's reading the
paper and see how they are
changing their work.
And they begin to have this
idea, again if you look at
feedback control, there's
governors on steam engines.
There's regulators
on arc lights.
There's automatic pilots
in airplanes.
And is even feedback amplifiers
in electrical
engineering.
But there's nobody who says,
hey, you know what, all that
stuff is really the same.
And now, we take for granted
as that's what you study in
control theory.
You don't study any one
of those areas.
You study the basic
phenomenon.
And that was the beginning
of what Brown was doing.
And it was really a coincidence
that right about
that moment, it goes underground
and it stays
underground for the whole war.
And that's really where when
Norbert Wiener comes out in
1948, and says, cybernetics,
feedback control, it's all
about this, he was just saying
something that had been secret
for eight years already
at that point.
But one of the things that got
me interested in this research
was, why was MIT's first digital
computer made by the
Servomechanisms Lab?
Because you don't necessarily
associate those two
things in your mind.
A servo, you think of as an
analog, mechanical thing and a
digital computer as this
funny electronic thing.
But during the war, it sort of--
it actually happens after
the war, but right
after the war.